gunfire in central Baghdad as Iraqi
security forces confront protesters for
a second day throughout Wednesday Iraqi
security forces placed a ring of armor
around Tahrir Square the focal point for
the protesters but they weren't deterred
by the show of force they came in large
numbers and fought running battles in
nearby streets and in other
neighborhoods their message to
government leaders is simple our demands
we won't work
we won't work if they do not want to
treat us as Iraqis then tell us we are
not Iraqi and we will find other
nationalities and migrate to other
countries we are demanding a change we
want the downfall of the whole
government that message of bringing down
the government will concern Prime
Minister are the loved al-mahdi his
office says he will meet protesters as
well as set up a commission to
investigate events including the deaths
of demonstrators quite who the Prime
Minister will meet is unclear analysts
suggest this is not a movement that
seems to be led by any political party
or religious movement but is born of
frustration no there is no one of them
to see coming behind that's of artistic
value because you saw that you see that
from the the slogan they arise they
arise everything there is no goodness no
guides and no religions the government
has cut off Internet services nationwide
a sign of how seriously the leadership
sees the power of social media used by
the protesters and it's not just the
capital Baghdad we're hearing that
protests have been taking place and at
least five other cities and that's going
to be concerning to the government now
what sources close to the Iraqi
government have told Al Jazeera is that
they're very worried about opposition
political parties and religious parties
joining the protesters because that
could swell numbers and make this a
major nationwide movement now right now
seemingly this protest movement is
actually leaderless what most analysts
are suggesting that it may well become
bigger and bigger in the coming days but
quite how effective it will be remains
to be seen Imran Khan al Jazeera bad